car j'adore j'ai eu ça lui a au
téléphone on a refait le monde parce que
j'appelle bernard montiel
ouais ouais c'est pas peur de l'appeler
dit quoi exactement 11 eu plein de
choses on se parle beauté voit la beauté
créé d'une crème dépilatoire au monde
bernard oui c'est vrai c'était très
intéressant j'ai pu poser des questions
je vous dit comment tu as fait pour
rester aussi beau aussi le temps affirmé
l'avoir c'est vrai que les ses conseils
beauté ses conseils longévité mois et
ses conseils couleurs du v n'en avait
jamais bien sûr je leur dis donc voilà
parce que c'est pour ça que tu as une
belle pomme normes élevées jamais là le
redis c'est une blague de cyril on me
ressource a en revanche non non mais
votez non j'aimerais bien que vous ayez
raison franchement moi je me regarde le
matin est bon dit il mange bien il boit
pas il va au soleil pour prendre soin de
sa peau parce qu'on a besoin du soleil
ouais c'est vrai il a de la chance
soixante trois ans bernard tu es
incroyable chez 1h57 bas ils sont là
croyez moi quand je dors bien la nuit et
alors je fais pipi vous savez j'ai
acheté un pistolet pour faire pipi la
nuit alors je ne veux plus mais non tu
sais ces trucs alors là qu'il a hélas le
glamour il est mort cinq à oui j'ai un
pistolet j'en ai marre de me lever si
vous voulez parce que les chiottes sont
plus loin donc j'ai acheté un pistolet
[Applaudissements]
sur les ondes de choc qui soit 250 me le
dire que ça fait chier normalement j'ai
acheté un pistolet contrôle de nos
hôpitaux tu sais tient à l'aube ou alors
moi évidemment tutelle qu'on préfère pas
parvenu combien de fois par année
passant je bois beaucoup d'eau justement
tu sois un couteau je vois pas donc je
bois de l'eau joies de l'eau forcément
tu fais pitié 5 heures du mat
non je regarde les infos ses news et tu
puisses dans le truc et je pisse dans le
truc alors je mets quatre pattes devant
le lycée très joli nom reste
je sais que ça casse le glam et oui
désolé nous a des goûts du domicile de
ses rêves oui c'est sincèrement c'est
vrai et à 5 heures du matin je me
réveille je fais pipi je suis content je
me rendors toi propos quelle est sa
ligne a n'ont pas plus tard j'ai même
une petite semaine pour nettoyer la
goutte des couches c'est quoi et quand
on dit que je suis beau glamour ma
charge d'envoyer la réalité d'un
pistolet alors elle a écouté j'aime bien
ah ouais mais je vous assure je vous le
recommande un vous qui me regarde et
vous avez comme sa hauteur alors c'est
vrai préscolaire à l'horaire de barre de
vie donc on peut pas encore compris non
mais c'est vrai et donc ouais nan mais
c'est en fait non c'est sérieux j'ai ce
à côté de mon lit
voilà il a cassé le mutisme rigoler
alain bernard sait pas mais c'est une
femme qui ne sépare que accueillir le
compliment ben il faut toujours se
dévaloriser valoriser la cie ont gardé
une analyse qui sait accueillir le
compliment regardé comme allibert mois
les matches mais je me lève palengat
exactement elle seule la famille
d'estelle ne fais je le fais sur mon
compte elle fait plus pis depuis 18 ans
que trois